Manchester United's being Manchester
United are typically involved from two
or three games per week at various
points in the season so the congested
fixture schedule must look very
different from a recovery perspective
when we're playing every three days
which we tend to do here
recovery is one of the key things we
need to take a look at we want to try
and make sure players are in positive
energy balance ensuring that they have
the science and sport Rigo products on a
daily basis making sure that every three
or four hours they're getting a good
protein hit the rego product delivered
that for us with the makeup of the
carbohydrate and protein formulation in
that product the real heavy sort periods
that we have and you know we could have
three games in seven days much of the
time they're the same players will be
selected to play for those things if a
nutrition plays a massive part it
shouldn't be a limiting factor for them
in performance or if they don't
concentrate on the nutrition then it
will be a limiting factor when you've
got a double week or even three games
like you know within a seven day period
it just remains a high carb week the
whole week the single most important
thing for us when the guys come off the
pitch after a game is to start that
recovery process that's focusing on
carbs fluids and proteins sagging
supporting the egos the sort of go-to
product for the guys and it takes all
three of those boxes for them even
during the game you know taking on
carbohydrate gels at halftime even if
the players don't need them in that game
you feel that you support them that
recovery process goes away we have
players that could play in excessive
sort of 50 games in the season for them
to be able to do that injury free they
must have the correct nutrition
otherwise they're going to fall foul of
injury
you
[Music]